vamos a hablar del efecto venturi esto
tiene que ver con el agua o cualquier
líquido que esté fluyendo a través de
una tubería imaginemos que tenemos a
esta agua que está fluyendo muy
tranquila por acá y de pronto se
encuentra esta construcción que va a
suceder acá bueno el agua tiene que
seguir fluyendo pero va a comenzar a
fluir más rápido acá en esta región de
la construcción y la razón de esto es
que tenemos cierta cantidad del líquido
que está fluyendo imaginemos todo lo que
está fluyendo en esta región de acá y
imaginemos que el agua tarda en recorrer
esta parte de acá hasta llegar a esta
sección transversal de aquí del inicio
hasta esta sección tarda un segundo en
llegar el agua todo este volumen se
mueve a través de esta sección de la
tubería en un segundo
bueno las leyes de la física nos dicen
que este mismo volumen tiene que pasar
por cada una de las porciones de esta
tubería ya que de otra forma pues a
dónde va a ir esta agua esta tubería
tendría que romperse o algo así así que
esta agua tiene que continuar su paso
así que está agua tiene que ir a algún
lado si esta cantidad de agua pasa por
aquí en un segundo esta misma cantidad
de agua tendrá que pasar por en esta
región pequeñita de aquí y tendrá que
hacerlo en un segundo la única forma en
que esto sea posible es que esté frente
de la superficie en lugar de pasar de
aquí a acá en un segundo este frente de
la superficie va a tener que cambiar su
forma y quizá el agua tenga que pasar de
aquí a acá en alguna fracción de segundo
ya que todo esto tiene
y juntarse para poder pasar aquí en la
misma cantidad de tiempo ya que sigue
llegando más agua por detrás la tasa del
volumen de flujo tiene que mantenerse
igual la tasa del volumen de flujo al
inicio de la tubería tiene que ser igual
a la tasa de volumen de flujo a la
salida de la tubería ya que esta agua
tiene que pasar por algún lado no es que
aquí desaparezca tiene que seguir
fluyendo aquí lo importante es que el
agua fluye mucho más rápido que en la
parte más amplia y muchas veces va mucho
más rápido en la región construida
mientras más pequeña sea esta área
comparada con la región de acá el flujo
del líquido va a ser más rápido porque
nos interesa esto bueno pues porque el
fluido que se mueve a mayor velocidad va
a tener menor presión porque un líquido
o un fluido que se mueve a mayor
velocidad tiene menor presión vamos a
ver la ecuación de bernouilli
ecuación de bernouilli nos dice que te
uno más row gh1 más un medio de error de
1 al cuadrado es igual a p número 2 más
row por g por h 2 más un medio de error
por b 2 al cuadrado y baja ya que esto
luce intimidante pero vamos a elegir un
punto aquí en p 1
este es nuestro punto 1 por lo que todo
este lado de la ecuación se refiere a
este punto y vamos a elegir el punto 2
aquí y todo el lado derecho de la
ecuación se refiere a este punto 2 noten
que ambos puntos se encuentran
básicamente a la misma altura así que
suponemos que aquí no hay una gran
diferencia de altura por lo que quitamos
estos elementos que involucran a la
altura aquí tenemos una presión en el
punto 1 y cierta velocidad del agua en
este punto uno podríamos poner esos
números de este lado y encontrar el
valor
en este otro lado sabemos que la
velocidad 2 es mayor
dijimos que esto tiene que ser así para
que se mantenga la tasa de flujo en la
tubería así que esta cantidad de aquí es
mayor pero sabemos que todo esto va a
ser igual a lo que tenemos en este otro
lado por lo que si este término aumenta
quiere decir que este término de la
presión va a disminuir para que cuando
se sumen se mantengan la igualdad con lo
que tenemos en este otro lado y eso se
le llama el principio de werniul y el
principio de brno le dice que cuando a
un fluido aumenta su velocidad va a
disminuir su presión y esto es algo que
no nos pareciera que tenga mucho sentido
siempre estamos esperando lo opuesto
pensamos que mientras más rápido se
mueva un fluido va a tener mucha presión
pero es justamente lo opuesto un fluido
de alta velocidad va a tener una menor
presión y esto se debe a la ecuación de
bernouilli
esto es lo que ocasiona el efecto
venturi el efecto venturi se refiere al
hecho de que si tenemos un fluído que se
encuentra dentro de un tubo y en ese
tubo quisiéramos tener una región con
menor presión por cualquiera que sea la
razón simplemente tenemos que poner una
sección más pequeña o una construcción
en esa tubería para reducir la presión
aquí en esta construcción tendremos un
flujo mucho más rápido y una menor
presión esta es la idea detrás del
efecto venturi básicamente lo que dice
este principio es que en donde tengamos
una construcción dentro de una tubería o
de un tubo vamos a tener una menor
presión y ya que estamos hablando del
flujo de algún líquido o de algún fluido
vamos a deshacernos de esto y ahora
imagínense que tenemos un muro de
ladrillos y tiene algún fluido que se
dirige hacia él ahora imaginemos que
esto es aire tenemos este fluido que va
hacia este muro de ladrillos aunque
pareciera un ejemplo algo ridículo del
principio de ver nulli pero quiero
demostrarles algo así que tengan
paciencia bueno este aire va hacia acá y
que va a suceder
bueno no puede pasar a través del muro
tiene que ir a algún lugar quizás este
de aquí se va por acá y a lo mejor este
otro también va hacia arriba quizás los
de este lado vayan hacia abajo pero la
porción de en medio básicamente termina
justo cuando llega al muro y ahí se
detiene va a haber cierta cantidad de
aire justo aquí en el medio que no se va
a estar moviendo qué tal si quisiéramos
conocer cuál es la presión que se
encuentra en este punto usando las
variables involucradas en este problema
nuevamente podemos usar la ecuación de
berlín y elegir dos puntos aquí
aquí tenemos el punto 1 y elegimos este
como punto 2 y ponemos la ecuación de
berlín y nuevamente digamos que estos
dos puntos se encuentran básicamente a
la misma altura por lo que aquí la
altura no es un factor que tomemos en
cuenta por lo que podemos omitir estos
términos de acá bueno conocemos la
velocidad del aire en el punto 2 no se
está moviendo está detenido se encuentra
estancado así que esto de aquí es 0 y
tenemos el enunciado de que la presión
en el punto 2 a veces también se le
llama la presión de estancamiento ya que
aquí el aire se encuentra completamente
detenido y ustedes me pueden decir a ver
un aumento yo pensé que el aire tendría
que moverse a algún lugar y si va a
algún lugar el punto es que hay cierta
cantidad de aire aquí que se encuentra
atrapado hay aire que pasa alrededor de
él pero queremos saber cuál es la
presión aquí bueno ya nos deshicimos de
estos términos acá y nos qué
con la presión en el punto 2 que es a lo
que yo llamo la presión de estancamiento
y eso tiene que ser igual a la presión
en el punto 1 más un medio de ro por la
velocidad del aire en el punto 1 al
cuadrado nos queda esta fórmula y
ustedes me pueden decir bueno y a mí
para qué me sirve esta fórmula ya que
pues normalmente nosotros no estamos
aventando aire hacia un muro de
ladrillos pero esto nos sirve para
construir un instrumento muy importante
que se llama el tubo de pitot el tubo de
pitot luce así y para qué usamos el tubo
de pitot pues se usa para medir la
velocidad de un fluido o si nos estamos
moviendo a través de un fluido es una
forma de medir nuestra velocidad lo que
sucede es que tenemos esta configuración
imaginemos que tenemos esto instalado en
un avión y vamos a volar a través de un
fluido que en este caso va a ser el aire
y va en esta dirección y está
envolviendo nuestro aparato volamos
hacia la izquierda y el aire nos rodea
un tubo de pitot siempre va a tener esta
sección que se encuentra de cara al
flujo de manera que el aire va a estar
entrando directamente en esta sección y
la clave es que esto está bloqueado no
puede salir aire de aquí tenemos aire
aquí que no se está moviendo y no se
mueve porque pues no tiene a donde ir no
hay ninguna forma de que pueda salir del
aire acá y además tenemos otra región
aquí arriba otra cámara en donde el aire
o el flujo va pasando por arriba y esta
tiene una abertura que se encuentra en
un ángulo recto con respecto a la
dirección del flujo y aquí no se está
moviendo el fluido la clave aquí es que
tenemos una forma de medir la diferencia
de presiones entre estas dos cámaras la
diferencia de presión aquí y la presión
acá imaginamos que aquí tenemos algún
tipo de membrana o algo que está
dividiendo estas dos secciones
que nos puede decir la diferencia de
presiones si la presión de este lado es
un poquito más grande que la presión de
este otro lado una de estas nos están
midiendo la presión aquí y otra nos está
midiendo la presión acá cuál será la
relación matemática entre estos pues la
que acabamos de encontrar justo está la
presión de estancamiento aquí el aire
nos estamos viendo aquí sabemos que la
velocidad del aire va a ser cero así que
la presión de estancamiento es una
presión aquí arriba suponiendo que hay
una diferencia de altura muy pequeña
imaginemos que este es un dispositivo
bastante pequeño y no es que tenga una
altura de 10 metros aquí las diferencias
de altura son minúsculas tenemos la
misma ecuación que antes esto es igual a
la presión en el punto 1 más un medio de
error de 1 al cuadrado y así es como
encontramos la velocidad o la rapidez de
despejamos nuestra velocidad 1 y nos
queda que es igual a la presión de
estancamiento
la presión en el punto 1 todo esto
multiplicado por 2 y dividido entre rojo
que es la densidad del aire y a todo
esto le vamos a sacar la raíz cuadrada
así que ese dispositivo nos permite
determinar la diferencia de presiones
que es lo que tenemos aquí también
debemos conocer la densidad del fluido o
en este caso del aire y eso nos da una
forma de determinar la velocidad del
fluido o en otras palabras la velocidad
de nuestra aeronave que se encuentra
atravesando el aire